ceci est le premier test de mon projet
de robotique lui s'est attaché mon grand
frère c'est le 84e veste bonjour je suis
d max il voulait aider l'humanité
les gens disent qui sera toujours là
tant qu'on se souviendra de lui
bonjour je suis b-max kadhafi m'a
programmé pour soigner les malades et
les blessés
vous vous remettrez allez je vais vous
scannez nom me scan pas canaux terminé
c'est pas croyable c'est comme faire un
cas lorsque walo bien il faut le
capturer que je ne suis pas rapide et
non tu es pour cela tapez dessus taxi
m'a tout appris sur la robotique
cet art de contredire mon image
réconfortante et rassurante du pub le
soleil
mais qu'est ce qui te rend batteries et
des chargeurs
c'était super qu'est ce que t'en dis mon
rang